the gateway is in select theaters and on
apple tv and everywhere you rent movies
starting on september 3rd and will be
available on blu-ray and dvd on
september 7th and on september 24th one
of my favorite tv shows goliath returns
to amazon prime for its final season he
will be on that as well one of the best
of the best bruce dern here on the rich
eisen show how are you sir
well first of all it's a treat for me
because uh
i watched you guys for a long long time
and uh
a guy you remember her name roger werner
uh no who's that
he started espn
okay he went to neutra i went to neutral
high school and went on calendar so did
he
and he started a division called speed
vision that's right
which they did a lot of all the car
racing around the world the formula one
and everything like that and speed
vision then was incorporated into espn
when they started 1984 or i don't know
what the date was but i thought it was
around that
and we did a show called the lost
drive-in
where we went around to the
uh drive-in theaters in america and
showed any
uh sports related movies that had to do
with uh speed you know car racing plane
racing uh you know uh
not track and field but anything with
motors or boats or anything like that
and so we went around and did that and
so i did a lot of motorcycle movies and
things like that in the 60s and all and
so they
they they were made for drive-ins so
that was that
but um
that uh
i thought it was a good roger warner was
the guy that
that started all that i thought and then
um
uh you remember the name edgar sherrick
yeah you're i'm i'm not batting oh for
two which means one more i might make
the hall of fame still there
he started wide wide world of sports in
54.
and his assistant was
his assistant was dick ebersole
who was a notre dame freak if you know
what i mean that's going to give up
notre dame everything had to be notre
dame this is that but eversolon went on
to run nbc sports and put on the
olympics and all that yes and that's
that's america now we're back
james
who was in a television series with rock
hudson at the time oh yes so now now
we're back in one for three
i've heard of him i've heard him that's
okay do you like sports trivia of
bruce dern go at it let's do it let's
play sports trivia what do you got for
me
what college
has supplied the most starting
quarterbacks
in the super bowl okay i think i know
the answer to this by the way this is
good this is good i think i know the
answer to this bruce dern the answer is
cal berkeley did i get it right
yes siree and there's six
okay and what makes it six is a trick
the first is joe cap
the second
is uh
craig morton
who started for two different teams in
the super bowl
dallas and denver yep
and then
[Music]
the fourth or the you know is vince
ferragamos who started at cal
couldn't play behind barkowski
so he went to nebraska and won a
national championship in the fifth or
sixth sarah
uh aaron aaron rodgers and um
jared goff
isn't that amazing cal berkeley has
spent has sent more quarterbacks
to tell people a pac-10 school they
start with ucla i will get over there
too and then they go to sc i mean
they're just uh people i'm 85 years old
and i got this down i spent all my life
just
loving uh you know
sports and so forth and so on and then
the other question is there are two
questions i had for this second question
yes yes
if you consider
hitting a major league pitch
the hardest thing to do
in all of sports
then this is the best world record ever
in
1986 playing third base for the boston
red sox
wade boggs
made 704
plate appearances
he was thrown over 5
200 pitches
he swung and missed making contact
with the baseball
27 times
and that's an old-time record right
there no doubt about that mr wing
sports i mean maybe 15 rounds of boxing
but i'm a wuss so i wouldn't know that
but i'm just saying that
that is a record and people say well
why'd boxie get in the first ballot
excuse me
just shut up i'm sorry
i mean
you know if that's not as amazing as
anybody can do i don't know what it is
that that's pretty big stuff the great
bruce dern here on the rich eisen show
uh i mean this is this is you know it's
interesting because we had pete rose on
a couple years ago and he's he he he was
pooh-poohing the idea that golfers say
hitting a golf ball is the toughest
thing ever he says he always tells
golfers your ball doesn't move you put
it on a tee he goes my ball he had no
idea what i was hitting you know it's
curveball he had no idea what's coming
100 miles an hour 80 miles an hour it's
just tougher to do there's no question
about that bruce you know no doubt but
do you remember when john crock
came up to pinch hit in the all-star
game against randy johnson and he had to
go against uh uh randy johnson oh sure
oh yeah and the first pitch randy
johnson threw to him
uh he never
saw the second pitch was right at his
head
and he backed out and it broke over the
plate
and the third one would have killed him
if it had hit anybody
and when he
he was called out three strikes
he laid his bat on the plate
he took his gloves off he put his helmet
on it and he turned around to the umpire
and the catcher was the kid from toronto
uh on that world championship team i
forget it i think pat borders pat
borders was his name i think yeah matt
right absolutely very good and uh he
said uh
it's not fair
[Laughter]
bruce stern here on that and the other
great story i heard um
i don't mean to think if i'm boring you
tell me no no but i do i do have some
questions for you though no doubt about
that i've got some last one let's go for
it uh when they tore up
the
parquet in the boston garden yes sir
that night
red auerbach was there and he was
sitting behind him will have a check and
casey jones
and a guy in a business suit walked
across the now empty floor all the
people were gone the stadium was full
everybody had their piece of parquet
and he walked up to red auerbach
and he bent down
and he put a police a piece of parquet
in his hand
and he said you know
coach
i
i don't see that you have a piece
you have to have a piece
because you built the building
and he put it in his lap and our box
says no no that that's for you people
and the guy just turned around having
left the piece in red's
lap
and walked
across the arena and out
and havoc came down and said
red um
he said what
he said what did derek sanderson just
say to you
how about
that about who built the garden
i got bruce stern here
it is a great story it is a great story
you must have so i got so many questions
for you but i only have a limited amount
go ahead do your thing no no here you go
bruce dern here on the rich eisen show
his new movie the gateway
is uh available uh tomorrow september
3rd on apple tv select theaters and
everywhere you rent movies blu-ray and
dvd on september 7th normally what i do
you know back in the day you were on my
podcast and i could talk to you for
about an hour and it was fantastic and
you told some great stories from back in
the day and the current day um but uh
what i like to do is play celebrity true
or false with uh with somebody go
through their career as best i can and
you tell me what's true or what's not
about what's better than written about
your career can you do that bruce
okay all right here we go if we got it
here's some production value for bruce
dern here on the rich eyes and she'll
hit it
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth
uh all right here's your first question
bruce dern um your first question you
were part of the actor's studio in new
york city when marilyn monroe was there
in the late 50s is that true or false
true what was that like
late 50s in early 1661 yeah who was
there what was that like 61. what was
that like
well first of all she was there to
observe because her private teacher
was lee strasberg
and he wanted her to come to the studio
to see the kind of acting work that we
were all working on to help her with
hers
rather than to make her get up and
perform in front of us because in the
actor's studio
after you do your little 10-minute scene
whatever it is
everybody in the class gets to raise
their hand and say what kind of work
they just saw from that actor or actress
and then mr strasberg sums it up and he
did not want to put her through that
so that's why she was there is that
right
okay and who else who else that was
there with you back in the day that you
were working on and becoming actors well
they all went to there were a bunch of
excuse expression guidos but i mean
there were a bunch of italian guys that
were all in a movie called hatful of
rain okay and it was tony franciosa with
it was harry gardino
and it was a huge hit on broadway and
then they made it as a movie and all
those guys became instant movie stars
and then they did a play off broadway
and the play was called end as a man
and uh ben gazar was the star of that
and uh george papard was in that
paul newman was in that uh and this is
in the mid 50s and i didn't come in
until 58
and um
so i wasn't there but that was the other
play that sent and they didn't have to
do it i'm involved in my first play on a
second play on broadway was the paul
newman geraldine page it was called
sweet burger youth it was a tennessee
williams play and i began my career
under contract to mr kazan
and he had five of us he had riptorn
pat hingle
geraldine page
brucie from winnetka
and lee remick
and those were the five that were under
contract so
i was very lucky that i got to start
there and now the big thing about us
is when uh
i came uh
to hollywood after three and a half
years in new york on broadway and
driving a freaking cab and everything um
i came out here and my generation got
the chance to still work with the
legends
nowadays they give us awards i mean
clint gets some jackets and i get them
red for whoever they are get legendary
awards and all this kind of promotion
we're not legends you can't be a legend
everybody knows what the hell we do
after school so how the hell can you be
private or anything like that but these
people were private which enabled them
to be bigger than life
bruce stern
when i went to kill john wayne and the
cowboys he'd never been killed in a
movie
they were putting bullet hits on him you
know what bullet is all right yeah i
mean that was my next question for you
bruce from winnetka as you refer to
yourself true or false that you received
death threats after you shot john
wayne's character in the back and the
cowboys so that's a that's a true story
that you got death threats this last
weekend
to this last weekend come on and we made
that movie in 71 so you're talking 50
years ago
he said to me while they were putting
these bullet hits on them oh
they're gonna hate you for this
and i said maybe
but in berkeley
i'm a freaking hero
and he laughed he put his arm on my
shoulder and he said
that's why
this
is in my movie
because he understands that bad guys
were funny otherwise we wouldn't be
talking about them 150 years later
so you bruce stern just recently got you
bruce dern just recently got a death
threat because you killed john wayne's
character in a movie 50 years ago that
just happened that's true
yeah to my face
i did a collectible show yeah
and a guy came up to me who was maybe
uh you know a
memorabilia card collector guy and he
said you know i really back in the 70s
you killed my buddy
and i said really who was that he said
john i said hey bud he died of cancer
get over it was a movie
and he said uh no you killed my buddy
and if i had seen you in person and i'd
have ripped you a new one
well you wouldn't have been the first
[Laughter]
wow so i mean it was and he was good you
know the great thing rich about those
people
they always were fabulous
to my generation of young actors
particularly because they saw us doing
stuff
they could never get to in their careers
because they were in the contract
system they were under contractor
studios and the studios always wanted to
play themselves
again and again and again which made
movie stars and that they were bigger in
life and every one of them that ever
helped me
you go back and you look at certain
movies that they were in and they say
well but john wayne was john wayne no go
back and look at the quiet man go back
and look at uh uh
true grit sure
yeah i mean look at look at the things
that everyone in the same way
um and they were very helpful to us for
two reasons one is they weren't able to
do what they saw we could do
and second of all they encouraged us to
go to the edge of the bluff and take
risks
i got uh bruce journey now when i worked
with robert mitchum for example we made
a sports movie called that championship
season
of course of course bruce
of course
and uh it's a good movie and
it really happened
because in 1956
scranton central
which was that high school
upset
overbrook
because they played four corners and
could stall
and their center
that jumped up at the center
remember the priest said to the our
center break his nose that center was
george raveling
really george right i love these stories
bruce stern here celebrity true or false
next one the film black sunday was
filmed during the actual super bowl 10
matchup between the steelers and cowboys
in the orange bowl is that true
or false true
were you there that day were you there
that day as well did you get to meet
chuck norris
i wasn't there the day right because
what they did on the day was they hired
the seven best cameramen in the world
and each one
had an assignment
cover starbuck
cover the crowd
cover the cheerleaders cover the
announcer some are all on uh you know uh
brookshire tom brookshire right
and uh they uh so each one had so they
put that all together now we went back
there
two weeks later the orange bowl yeah to
do the ending of the movie
because what happened was
when the movie ended it ended exactly
like the cover of the book
when robert shaw
is on his way in the helicopter to pull
me and mark keller out of the sky
from with the uh the blimp
uh
on the way as we approach the sky if you
remember the cover of the book the
picture is
a shadow comes over the stadium and it's
the sun at the sunny day
and the shadow comes over the stadium
and all the people look to see the
shadow
and it's the blimp
starting to crush the light standards
above the stadium
and that's the end
and it said black sunday
think about it
paramount went nuts when they saw it
and they said you can't end the movie
like that the jewish guy's got to win
he's got to win because charles boudon
was the head of paramount at the time
and they didn't think it was appropriate
so we had to go back and shoot at shaw
coming and dragging it out over the
ocean so all the darts went in the ocean
but i'll tell you something rich it's
the only movie
that i've ever made
that i would never make again right
right and the reason being
someone could do that
i hear you wow
a blimp can only go 60 knots
and it can't go above 4 200 feet
so
if you can get it off the ground and arm
it
you're on your way
i thought it was a good movie i i
i you know i've been a sports fan but
i'm not an autographed person because i
admire too much i know i went to a uh
for a while my daughter laura was
married to ben harper
and the singer and ben harper was an
avid avid laker fan and a kobe fan and
kobe loved all his music and everything
and uh
so we went to a game and the lakers won
a playoff game against portland
and then for some reason
started booing rasheed wallace
and i just turned to him we were
together laura me and him
at the game and i said you know
something
i've never booed anyone in my life
and he said but mr d he's the enemy
i said ben
it's a game
and he's doing something i can't do
and you got it bruce stern here on the
rich eisenhower
i got i got one last one for you bruce
here's the last one for you go ahead all
right last one for you this has nothing
to do with entertainment but is it true
or false that eleanor roosevelt was a
babysitter of yours is that true
my grandfather dern was secretary of war
he died the week i was born
when i was three years old or two years
old
i
was out at highwood where their home is
another summer home people don't know
much about it but the roosevelts had and
uh
i was nine in 1944
and we stayed two days
at that house
uh my grandfather was already dead eight
years but my father
uh my godfather was adelaide stevenson
and my father and him were law partners
at sibling austin in chicago and so uh
my dad's dad was the one who was
secretary of war and so we went there
and when we went there she invited us
and he was on his way to yalta
to that big conference he had with
churchill stalin him and uh charles de
gaulle
and uh
so
i rode my bike that afternoon and i hit
a tree and i had a concussion and in
those days
when you had a concussion they just
strapped your head with a big rubber
strap so you couldn't move it up or down
or sideways or anything
and when i kind of came to maybe
for the first time i realized something
which is now maybe six hours after i
whacked my head
on my bicycle
i looked
over to the side and was kind of
bleary-eyed and i saw this uh lady with
uh uh i
see a lady i could just see the knees
and i looked above the knees and there
was a
a glasses and a lap
and in the lap was a book
and the glass and the lap were in the
book and i looked all the way up and it
was eleanor roosevelt
and she was watching me while my parents
were somewhere else wow
so you're the only one bruce dern there
he's not a grandmother no no so but
you're you're you're i did have uh you
know like my godfather ran for president
twice my uh our uncle is archibald
mcleish my middle name is macleish bruce
mccree stern and he was a poet laureate
and won five pulitzer surprises as a
poet
and uh my my grandmother's roommate
my grandmother makrish's roommate at
wellesley was an eighteen-year-old
madame shankai sheck
and when i wrote a book
in 2007 i wrote a book called things i
said but probably shouldn't have
and it did
it did really well
on amazon or anything else that summer
of 2007.
but in it uh
when uh well i'll leave you with this
laura
myself
and her mother diane ladd
are the only family in the history of
hollywood
that all of us have stars on hollywood
boulevard other families plenty of them
but never mother father child that's
amazing you know what uh
garcetti who was the guy that
presented us our awards that day
uh you know here's your walk star of
fame so what and so on he says what does
all this mean to you
you know today and everything what
special connotation all does it have
and i said well i'll tell you what it
means
it means to me that a bunch of folks got
together
and said bruce dern could play
and that's the way i end my book that's
my last line in the book that's all i
hope for out of this nobody's better
than anybody else but when they can run
around and copy this and kobe that
oscar retired
with a triple double
you know what bruce is for his career
but i mean he retired in a season where
he had a triple double it's amazing
bruce like again you're you're like
brewster and you're like the only guy
who could connect fdr hitchcock and
tarantino all in one
it's amazing man oh that's very nice oh
come on i'll leave you with one okay
i'll leave you with the last question
and you can't answer it now but
in
division one college sports
there are
190 something
or 171
something like that division one teams
that compete in
basketball
yeah 31 of them
have nicknames that do not end in s
what are they oh my gosh and there's a
hundred and forty all ending okay well
that that's how about this
one to begin with
because stanford cardinals yeah the
cardinal that's a good one you know and
and that's my homework for the next time
but to make sure that there is a next
time i don't want to get your people
upset you want to talk about the gateway
before i let you go bruce what you like
about i'll talk about whatever you want
to keep me on for it's not my time it's
your time
to talk to you all day
you know why because if i have game what
the hell do you guys have there we've
got
i appreciate that bruce we've we've got
we've all got game what do you like
about the gateway that's available uh
everywhere you rent movies
apple tv and select theaters
i like about it is first way the gateway
stands for saint louis
and that's the gateway you know the big
archway there and so the movie takes
place in st louis in like the mid 80s
and
a guy is a social worker
who just got out of jail
about five years earlier and has been a
social worker and that's the guy shea
wiggum place
and he has a wife
and a daughter 10 and a father and i'm
his father
and uh
the bad guys are after him
to commit one more big crime since he's
been out with them
and uh
i try and convince my son it's okay
not to go back there
i was there he was there and that's what
the movie's about
and he gives up his life
literally
to save
me and his daughter
and
is
white
and again that's available on blu-ray
and
right available on blu-ray and dvd
september 7.
and then
we finished this goliath will be on on
the 24th of september i can't wait one
thing they're doing good this year
they're giving you all eight sepa
episodes the first day in other words
you could binge watch the whole series
in one day the 24th of september if you
were crazy enough you know or bored
enough but the point is that it's really
good and then this do you watch it i do
i can't get enough we've had billy bob
on many times to promote it i can't get
enough all right he's the best i can't
get enough of it gave me as a gift
he gave me a baseball bat signed to me
by stan musial
and on the bat it says
to bruce
from a great fan stan
musial that's the only relic i have no
except that and i have a baseball signed
by dave drovecki
and uh
okay
they say that
in the stadium that day you could hear
the crack when he threw the pitch oh my
gosh gosh
you never heard that i've i know i have
heard that i just didn't i didn't know
you out of dave gervecky baseball but
but billy bob you know he he played i
think he tried to make the royals once
he told a story like he he's he's tried
the cardinals the cardinals okay i know
it was i knew it was missouri based um
so
i guess one last one before you go bruce
do you do you have a good tarantino
story give me your favorite quentin
tarantino story i'm such a die-hard fan
of his and obviously you're so terrific
in his films you got a good tarantino
story i'll give you one uh i'd never met
him until a month before he went to do
django okay
and he called me up and he said look
you're the icon of your generation
you don't get credit for it yet
uh i had not done nebraska when he
called me okay and uh so he said so i
have to have you in my movie i don't
have a role for you
if you came down here for a day and i
wrote a scene for you would you do it in
new orleans they were shooting their
moons i said sure
so i did that then we go to the hateful
eight which we shot
a thousand four hundred feet fourteen
hundred feet above
telluride colorado which is 8 900 feet
so we were 10
500 feet
and we started in october and finished
in june
106
shooting days
and uh what happened was when sam
jackson gets all the stuff where he's
telling me about what he did to my son
and you're watching it on the screen and
everything like that
uh
he was having to break sentences
because he couldn't get his breath
so quentin
disassembled the cabin after four months
we had two weeks off in march
and we went
back to hollywood they brought the cabin
back to hollywood rebuilt it log by log
on the set
and that following monday we went back
to work to do a lot of the interior
stuff where you all the outside stuff
had been done and half of the inside
stuff
so we were back there
so it was fine so we walk on the set
the first day
and uh we all have our wardrobe on you
know and everybody look like they've
just gotten done uh coming back from
alaska
or something like that and all that
heavy gear
and uh we were very hot and quinn comes
in his car and he goes under the stage
and he says hi to all of us and he goes
on the stage
and we go on the stage
and the guy has refrigerated the stage
in hollywood
to 22 degrees fahrenheit
so he could see our breath
give me a break
the point is if we had done it at the
altitude sam would have been in
everybody else catching their breath
after all these long things and the
audience wouldn't know what the hell it
was about right
so he wanted he saw a breath there so he
wanted to see our breath that's that's
acquaintance story the other quentin
story is
i've been able to work in my life i feel
blessed enough that i was uh able to
work with six directing geniuses and not
in order of importance but just they are
mr kazan
mr hitchcock a kid named douglas
trumbull who directed a movie i did
called silent running which is about my
companions in space and then he also
directed brainstorm the movie which
natalie wood passed away on but when he
was 19 years old he won the academy
award for special effects as a senior in
huntington edison high school
down here in orange county
for 2001
at 19. he did if that's why he's a
genius and the other three are francis
coppola quentin tarantino and alexander
payne who directed nebraska
and uh the reason i call them geniuses
and other guys i'm leaving out how ashby
i'm living out john frank and i'm i'm
leaving out you know a lot of really
outstanding directors
is there are what makes them geniuses is
their approachability on a set
every single
member of the crew from the honey wagon
to the grips to the guys up in the loft
with the following spots anybody
is invited at any time to walk up to any
one of those directors and say sir
what is my exact job in this shot
and they'll tell you gladly
because they're all professors
you know what i mean i mean they don't
have the credentials but they got the
credentials for us and when people say
to me and to jack and dennis hopper when
we were all coming up doing all those
biker movies you guys none of you guys
finished college i went to penn for two
years and quit
uh
and uh
jack never went redford went for a week
at colorado uh clinton never went uh
burt did go burt reynolds because he was
the first quarterback to take florida
state to a road uh to a bowl game you
know that
and uh so anyway so all of these guys
but you know where we did go we went to
the university of corman
because roger corman
made movies all through the late 50s and
60s
for three hundred thousand dollars in 10
days
and every actor who was one of the stars
of it
had to do a job behind the camera as
well as his acting job so we learned how
to make the movies they're getting back
to making now
the gateway was made for like a million
million two hundred thousand dollars
and when we did nebraska the big fight
with paramount for alexander payne was
they did not want to make it in black
and white
they said in europe there's no resale
value in black and white it has to be
color and i asked brad gray who was
running the studio at the time he's
passed now
i said
i don't understand
why are you mixing the black and white
he said because who's going to give a
damn about some old drunk geezer with a
dream from a flyover state
and i said wait a second he said we
don't do business in those states i said
well how many states are flyover states
brett
he said nine
the dakotas montana idaho
uh
utah nebraska kansas iowa there are the
flyover states and i said hey brad wait
a minute
you're not making the movie because of
that
well sir what do you think they call
that area of this country he said i
don't know bleak drab
gray
i said no sir they call it the heartland
and now you said to alexander right then
make your movie but i'm only going to
give you yeah i'm taking ten thousand
dollars or ten million dollars out of
your budget
well alexander and i smile because
for a million dollars
we made four movies with roger corman so
we're back to the day where you you cut
every corner you broke every rule i mean
we never had police permits or anything
else we just went and shot it and the
first movie i did for roger uh was
called the wild angels starred me and
peter fonda and nancy sinatra
and uh
it was a biker movie you know uh we were
hell's angels i love it and uh
jack wrote the script for the next one
which was called uh the trip
and uh
it was it was just an era
and you know what i i remember one time
that ron howard i did a movie for him
called the burbs yes uh with tom hanks
also is a very funny movie he's cute and
uh
in the burbs
uh hanks is a pathetic cleveland fan i
mean uh including an indian fan and he
grew up in sacramento some and get over
it
but i mean he's uh anyway so he he's
he's an avid baseball fan like that but
while we were doing the movie
um
one day
uh
he brought two guests
well one of the two guests was cowboy
joe west
who was his first year as an umpire and
this was 1988.
and i forget the other guy he brought
with him was a
guy who looked just like steve garvey
that size that build and everything else
and they were the two that came together
that day
but uh joe west is known to have with if
you know what i mean i'm behind the
plate or on that yeah
so i grew up
i grew up with an appreciation
and to this day it's my greatest
appreciation can i use this word or not
go for it
yes
i really admire people that get
done
so do i bruce stern and you certainly
and you certainly are one of them too
man and i i
i when you talk to one people's got it
done come on
i can't shake paul giamatti's hand
i did it
shut up the guy did it
he got more hits than anybody for a
reason he could hit
and i'll tell you the i'll leave you i
promise to leave you with this okay the
greatest billy bob took me one time uh
when the cardinals were here is a
cardinal fan i'm a dodger fan so we went
to a cardinal dodger game we were
sitting down in the dugout with hal
mcrae
and uh
uh let's see how mccray and somebody
else and how mcrae was a really really
good hitter for kansas city um when he
played he was a good player and he was
there and along came greg maddox who had
just come to the dodgers
and uh
he was very fond of a couple of movies
that i'd done particularly one i did
many many years ago called they shoot
horses don't they which was about dance
marathons in the 30s
and uh so we started talking and i said
and can i ask you a question you know
billy pitched in high school he was a
very good pitcher in american legion and
high school age and his dad billy's dad
was one of the best basketball high
school basketball coaches in america
um and uh
through that i got to meet nolan
richardson and uh all over you know uh
what's his name the kid gay on that team
the arkansas team that won the national
championship and what's his name
williamson yeah corliss williamson yeah
cordless
right so he said to me uh
i said what what what are the rules in
baseball that we don't ever get to know
he said i'll tell you and billy one
right now
this is greg maddox you cannot make a
living
in the major leagues throwing strikes
you gotta learn to paint the edge
if you throw strikes
they're too good
they'll beat your brains out
he's the king of that and later i got to
meet tom saver he told me the exact same
thing not in the same words
but i just thought from maddox because
that's what he did he didn't throw
strikes but you thought they were
strikes that's what makes the wade bog
statistic
i mean
he swung
i don't know how many times
he says over over about
3 000 and i only missed
touching the ball 27.
and he wasn't begging to get in the hall
of fame he was already in it
but i mean i'm i'm knocked out and now i
after i wrote that first book i always
wanted to write a book about people
that finished second
i've always interested in the people
that were right there
and didn't quite do it but were within
an eighth of an inch of other people
fascinating
that's a fascinating idea to say the
least that no doubt about that hey oh
well i mean and i mean and i'll walk for
life i mean the other thing i remember
kazan took me one day when i was in new
york with him and they were building
some i don't know 90 story building or
anything he said what's interesting he
says you love trivia what's what's
interesting this 1959. what's
interesting trivia about that building i
said nothing
he says anybody on that building that
you can see if you had binoculars yeah
they're just specs to you now
that you can see
above the 20th floor
is a mohawk indian
because the only ones that'll walk
the burgers and the beans without any
framing are mohawk indians
and i love that and that's that's i i
look for in life things that people
don't get the same way in sports
i mean to me
um
you know the the greatest
you remember about greenspan of course
the olympic bill of course yes okay
well he was kind of a friend of mine and
uh he had a script he wanted me to do
about a guy
who uh
was
40 years old
and was basically
uh not quite as good as nolan ryan but
as good and that winter
he realized he could never pitch anymore
and he had a deal
from the yankees
for two years
and this is in the 80s for 20 million
dollars that's a lot to pitch the next
season
and
the guy's debate on whether to take it
or honor the sport
is what the movie was about
and he ends up not taking it
bruce i appreciate the time man this has
been a total blast for all of us here on
this show the next
i mean
i'd love to i'd love to
get you back and just not even have you
on the show just do a whole podcast chat
and just keep going if you'd be up for
that
i used to do costus's show one time a
year because uh um i was a good runner
when i went to college i mean a half
mile i was in the ivy league i went to
penn i only ran like 154 or something
like that but this is when the world
record was only 147.
now they're stripped from uh
rhodesia and his name is rhodesia
he's not called rhodesia anymore
zimbabwe or whatever it is but that he
runs 141 8.
it's amazing and uh talk about not uh
and the only other time i ever heard
like the cross quote it's not fair yeah
is uh these guys that had to run against
usain bolt
because he's not taking
[Laughter]
and after 40 meters he just runs off and
leaves human
later that's it that's it uh the gateway
is in select theaters on apple tv at tv
and everywhere you rent movies tomorrow
and will be available on blu-ray and dvd
on september 7th and cannot wait to see
the final season of goliath
on
oh he's in that too
yeah did you see whiplash of course the
drummer kid movie oh yeah that's jk
simmons yeah yeah the guy does all the
state farm commercials actually yeah
he's in that too
he and i are brothers
and i are brothers and this season is
about
we are pharma
and we are still selling an addictive
drug and getting away with it and billy
bob's firm comes after us
and then will come a story
and that's what our show is about i
cannot wait for them the other thing i
will say to you and all the people i
can't believe anybody's
still awake listen all that i come up
with but anyway uh it says on the call
sheet where we work to be continued
i'm saying that to you thank you to
please honor me with calling me back
someday on any kind of forum you want
just a private phone call
just uh to be on your show or not to be
on your show
because
there's i can name some that don't
but you
above everybody else
way back at the very beginning when i
started watching you there are some
people in the world that get it
you not only get it rich
you get it all
and that's what i love about you and
that's what i love about you guys are
trying to do on the air every day only
you present it and produce it in a way
that's palpable to everybody
even the notre dame fans
[Laughter]
bless you bruce stern you can be sure i
will be calling you soon thanks for
coming on
thank you rich very much my honor my
right back at you that's bruce dern here
on the rich eisen show